heureusement donc sur la réalité de
l'industrie porno c'est une industrie de
production de films dont la
particularité est de ne pas être du
cinéma les actes sexuels sont réels les
pénétrations sont réels les coûts et les
tortures aux voies sont réels le tout
est produit pour obtenir un maximum
d'audience et donc développer un marché
et un chiffre d'affaires qui sont
colossaux pour cela il faut recruter ce
qu'on appelle des actrices ou des
acteurs qui sont en réalité des
personnes à qui l'on demande un
consentement on extorque un consentement
par contraints par leur volet de
vulnérabilité parce qu'elles ont besoin
d'argent parce qu'elles sont en
situation de fragilité et l on sent ce
faux consentement des actes violents et
sans désir
et cela on le voit très vite constitue
non seulement une violence en soi comme
l'est la prostitution mais une violence
décuplée dans la pornographie
pour comprendre cela les témoignages
sont fondamentaux nous plions nous
publions dans notre revue prostitution
et société en 2016 le témoignage de
nadia qui dit le xc des viols à
répétition c'est inhumain ce sera le
témoignage est de loin le plus lu sur
notre site je vous en cite un extrait
mois la beurette entre guillemets
j'étais la seule arabe le porno est un
milieu fermé et très raciste mais ils
utilisent toutes sortes de femmes j'en
ai même vu une de 200 kg et il réunit
toutes les perversions imaginables quand
on se rebelle on nous dit il ya de la
demande il ya ce qu'on appelle le gonzo
on prend des coups très violents on se
fait cracher dessus tiré par les cheveux
j'ai tourné comme seule femme avec 35
type tous masqués j'ai eu la peau brûlée
par le sperme j'avais dit pas de scato
pas du ropa de zoophilie il a fallu que
je me batte sans arrêt j'ai connu une
fille qui s'est suicidé après avoir
tourné des scènes avec un chien le truc
tournait sur internet elle avait 18 ans
maintenant je réalise que la
pornographie c'est de l' esclavage
moderne j'ai été vraiment humiliée à
côté j'ai trouvé que dans la
prostitution il y avait au moins des
hommes gentils j'ai été violée une seule
fois j'ai pas été torturé le x et des
viols à répétition
c'est inhumain